we've seen that the combination of a
grand unified theory with a quantized
account of gravitation is called a
theory of everything by physicists
in this conversation we want to see how
seriously to take the word everything in
this phrase
if researchers succeed in the ultimate
goal of physics a single coherent theory
that unifies the working of all foreign
known forces in the universe what does
this mean for a picture of reality
would it mean that we not only completed
physics but also completed our inventory
of the furniture of existence
what a theory that explains how all
matter energy and interactions among in
between them in terms of field values
and symmetries give us an exhaustive
account of all we should consider to be
real
this view hinges on what we've discussed
as the doctrine called reductionism
that is that everything studied in every
science reduces ultimately the physics
this reductionist position is committed
to two claims
first
everything that exists is made up of
nothing more than the elements of
physics there are no extra physical
entities in the world and two
the laws and vocabulary of each science
are just shorthand for a more
complicated set of laws that can be set
out fully in the vocabulary of physics
we'll discuss the first of these at
length here and touch on the second just
a little because the second proposition
will be investigated in more detail
later in the course
reductionists contend that everything in
the universe is made up of atoms and
energy
the long-standing resistance to this
claim points to the existence of life as
a metaphysically different kind of thing
okay if we take a living being
immediately before and then the instant
after death
all the atoms that were there beforehand
are thereafter but the thing is
fundamentally different right we
differentiate linguistically between a
person and a corpse
we think intuitively that the two are
different right another word we use for
corpse in ordinary language is body
right when we say somebody has died we
say that his or her body is here but
that he or she that is the person is
gone we equate being a person with not
just having a body but also something
else
traditionally this something else is a
soul
this two-part picture of reality that
there are two separate sorts of things
in reality physical bodies and
non-physical souls is what philosophers
call metaphysical dualism
the great name attached to dualism is
rene descartes who's already come up in
a number of our conversations
recall descartes evil demon thought
experiment we talked about in the very
first lecture right descartes said
consider the possibility that we are
being fooled by an evil demon who's
putting false ideas in our minds right
he's not saying it's true but argues
that it's conceivable merely possible
and if it were true
then
any given thing i think any proposition
i believe could be false right put into
my brain by the demon
hence i could believe nothing about the
material world
not even that it exists
since it all may be an illusion the
result of a complex hallucination
created in my mind by the demon
seems like i can believe nothing about
reality but he realizes there is one
thing even the evil demon could not
wrongly convince me of that i exist
the demon could not fool me into wrongly
believing that i exist because i would
have to exist in order to be fooled
the demon would have to create the
thought of existence but the thought
requires a thinker and thinking is doing
and doing requires a doer
if i'm thinking i must exist and to be
fooled i must first think so
i can't be wrong about my belief that i
exist
but what am i
i'm not the person i think i am with the
body i think i have in the world i think
i inhabit all those beliefs could be the
result of the demon's handiwork
the only thing i have the right to
believe with absolute certainty
is that i am a thinking thing a thing
that thinks a mind
and so descartes concludes
the mind exists separate from the body
now he later goes on to try to prove
with mathematical certainty that the
body exists and that there are absolute
laws of mechanics that the body has to
obey but
these laws are the laws of matter
not those of the mind
mind and body are completely different
things different kinds of substances
reality is comprised of two separate
realms the material world governed by
the immutable laws of physics and the
world of mind that's governed by logic
or psychological rules or ethical rules
or
no rules at all
the human mind seems to be a different
sort of thing endowed with a very
important property
free will
we choose to do what we want
the problem for descartes
is that what we want is not just mental
but often physical we want things we
want to do things
this means that these two separate
realms the world of matter and the world
of mind must interact with each other
this is problematic
on the one hand we know that matter
influences mind and in the classroom
i'll demonstrate this by walking up
right to the big desk that's in the
front of the classroom which is often a
laminated plywood top with metal sides
and i'll kick the side the desk really
hard and the result is a huge
reverberating metallic bang
i'll then limp around the front of the
room pretending to be injured i asked
what just happened
and we see that there was a physical
interaction body to body when my toes
hit the desk and rapidly contracted from
the force
but this rapid contraction of my toes
had a seemingly non-material effect it
gave rise to an idea a mental experience
at first pain
then the thought don't kick solid things
you idiot so we have body to body
interactions giving rise to a mental
event an idea an experience
in the other direction we have a sense
that the mind influences matter
what i'll do then is i'll ask one of my
students to please write the word
guacamole on the top of his page class
notes
when completed i asked the student why
the name of this zesty avocado dip is
scrawled in his notebook and the
response is usually because you asked me
to
i then asked the student to stand up and
flap his arms while clucking like a
chicken
invariably the student declines when i
ask why
he says that he doesn't want to
so the reason the word guacamole appears
in the notes is not because i made you
do it but because you wanted to write it
wanting desiring willing is a mental
state and somehow the idea in your head
caused your hand to move in a very
particular way that gave rise to exactly
what you wanted to happen
we do not often go to write a word and
have a completely different word show up
our minds seem to control our hand
so
it looks like we have two completely
different things material objects and
ideas and they are different sort of
entities right i can have a basketball
and i can have the idea of a basketball
the two are not the same
one is material the other is mental one
has size shape weight location the other
doesn't
the basketball is orange and round
the idea of the basketball is the idea
of a round orange thing but it's not an
orange idea or a round idea
the properties of material and mental
entities seem completely different yet
the material seems to give rise to the
mental through perception and the mental
appears to give rise to the physical
through acts of will
we seem to have interaction between them
but how
it's the size shape and mass of one
object that lets it act on another if
ideas have no physical properties how
can they give rise to physical movements
like the hand moving the pen across the
paper
this problem of interaction seems to
plague the move to include non-material
things in the universe to add a
completely new category of stuff to
reality
descartes tried to solve this problem
anatomically he knew that the brain was
the bodily organ responsible for action
so the mechanism by which the mind
interacted with the world must reside
there he also knew that there's a
network of nerves through the body that
are in part responsible for taking data
about the interaction of the world and
the body back to the brain where they
somehow gave rise to observation and
were responsible for the movement of the
muscles by the mind
so he figured that these nerves would be
tubes much like the veins and arteries
also criss-crossing the body
when veins and arteries carry blood
pumped by the heart
these nerve tubes would carry a
different fluid
animal spirits that is spirits in the
sense of a liquid not spirit in the
sense of a soul although for descartes
soul mind and spirit would all have the
same sense
it's through disturbances in the flow of
the animal spirits that the mind would
receive news of the physical world
send out its commands to the body
according to descartes hypothesis
the part of the brain responsible for
this is the pineal gland a small part of
the brain that had the twin virtues of
being centrally located and descartes
not having any idea what else it might
be doing
it's through the manipulation of the
animal spirits by the pineal gland that
the mind connects with the body
that we have the interaction between
these two distinct parts of reality now
turns out of course that this theory
fails
we know that the nerves don't carry a
subtle fluid and that the pineal gland
is responsible for producing melatonin a
hormone that plays a crucial role in
sleep in our bodily rhythms but
the central metaphysical question is
still with us
is there a single sort of thing in
reality just material or is there some
other sort of entity for descartes this
other sort of entity was a soul and
particular to humans animals he thought
for theological reasons cannot have
minds or souls
clearly descartes did not have pets
at descartes time throughout paris
appeared hydraulic statues fountains
that didn't just shoot out water but
used the water pressure to move parts of
the statues making up the fountain and
so also making sounds like a calliope so
from a distance parisians would see
human shaped figures moving and playing
music
they were animated like persons even
though they had no mind
descartes thought this is what animals
were complicated automata complex
organic robots over time the theology
was weaned from the duelist's view and
living things were simply held to
possess what french philosopher henry
barakson called an elan vital a vital
force or vital impulse what the german
thinker arthur schopenhauer called the
will to be
living things have a will that
non-living things do not it's this will
this power to desire and cause to happen
through internal means that separates
the living in the universe from the
non-living
the brain is relevant here it's
necessary but it's not sufficient we
could take a cat scan
and see that when we have certain kinds
of thoughts a certain area of the brain
is active right when we have a certain
sort of desire a different section is
engaged when we have a certain sort of
sensory experience a completely
different region lights up
we can absolutely conclude that there is
a correlation
between the state of the brain and a
human experience but the dual list will
say that this correlation is a relation
between
two different things
the materialist someone who denies
dualism someone who contends that
there's only one sort of metaphysical
entity and that reality is strictly and
solely material must hold that brain
states and mind states are the same
thing that they're different
descriptions of the same occurrence
the dual list on the other hand holds
that brain states and mind states are
fundamentally different
we can point to the spot in the brain
that's active when i feel pain in my
stub toe but the pain i feel the
experience of pain is not the same thing
as the neural activity the two are
linked but they're different according
to the duel list
they are one and the same according to
the materialist but consciousness for
the dualist is completely different it's
non-material
one physicist who made this case was
eugene vigner he was concerned with what
we've seen in quantum mechanics as the
measurement problem
okay recall that the equation governing
the development of quantum systems is
the schrodinger equation
when a quantum system is not observed it
occupies a state of superposition that
is it's in a combination
of every possible state it could occupy
the schrodinger equation describes how
this superposition develops according to
the potential energy in the environment
of the system
but
the instant we observe the system
it fails to be in the superposed state
but instead appears in one and only one
of the possible states
we can never predict which one it will
be the schrodinger equation gives us the
odds that we'll find it in each of the
possibilities but the best we get is
this probability
the problem here
is that we have a physical law in the
schrodinger equation that always holds
except when we look
physicists were bothered by three
aspects one
how can you have a universal law of the
universe that can be violated
two
why is the violation subject to
randomness right this was einstein's
problem and three
what is it about us looking at something
that causes the violation it's this
third question that eugene victor tried
to answer
one interesting thing about quantum
systems is that they become entangled
right we talked about this earlier with
respect to the identity of particles
right if two electrons bounce off one
another
right we may be able to label them as
bob and carol coming in but we can't say
which one is bob and which one is carol
coming out the best we could do is say
one is now 10 and one is now alice right
the two electrons cease to be
independent things in the world that
subsist and persist but rather are just
disturbances of a particular sort in the
underlying field
when we talk about the behavior of the
field the reality of things themselves
is lost
we say in this way that the parts of the
system have become entangled and we can
only describe the system as a whole
this is what makes the thought
experiment called schrodinger's cat so
troubling
the idea is that we can easily create
what are called spin correlated
particles okay electrons for example
have a property called spin not that
they're little ping-pong balls actually
spinning but the effect is much like
what physicists recognize in angular
momentum of a rotating charged object
right a thing can be said to spin
clockwise or counterclockwise and there
are different effects for each now we
can create pairs of electrons such that
when we don't look at them both are in
superposed states of clockwise and
counterclockwise but as soon as we
observe one
both collapse into a single state of
clockwise or counterclockwise such that
one is always the opposite of the other
but we never know which will be which
it's the equivalent of a quantum coin
flip
so
attach the apparatus that creates these
pairs to a spin detector that will
observe the spin of one of these
particles now attach the detector to a
circuit connected to a poison gas
canister such that if the detected
particle is spinning clockwise
the circuit does nothing
if the detected particle is spinning
counterclockwise the canister is opened
allowing the gas to escape finally
place the canister in a closed box
containing a cat
now
we push the button
a correlated pair of electrons is
emitted the detector determines the spin
of one if the electron collapse from its
superposed state into a clockwise spin
nothing happens and the cat lives
if the electron collapse from its
superposed state into the
counterclockwise spin
then the detector sends the signal
through the circuit the gas escapes the
cat dies
but
suppose we push the button and don't
look in the box
the detector is made up of atoms it's a
physical thing subject to the laws of
quantum mechanics
if we've not observed the detector its
atoms will be in their superposed state
which is now entangled with that of the
emitted electron
the circuit likewise just more atoms
which are unobserved and so they obey
schrodinger's equation in a way that has
them entangled with the state of the
larger system
and it's with the canister of gas and
the cat
assuming a picture of the cat like that
at descartes in which the cat has
no mind capable of making observations
right all of these are just atoms all of
these unobserved and therefore all of
these in superposed states in a grand
entangled system when we don't observe
the system it's in one big superposed
state meaning the cat is in the
superposed state of alive and dead
it's not half dead it's not in the
process of dying but rather it's in the
superposed state of being both alive and
dead but the instant we open the door
and look inside the cage
we see either a dead or a live cat the
wave function collapses into just one
state
but wait a minute we're just atoms too
right
we too should be part of the system as
should the rest of the universe there
should be no collapsing from the two
superposed state into a single property
state
schrodinger's equation should always
hold in violent
where is the only place in the process
that a different sort of entity could be
active
wigner concluded that the only place is
in the making of the observation an
observation is when we learn of the
result when our consciousness becomes
involved
other than our consciousness there's
nothing but atoms here and nothing that
should affect the system to cause the
collapse
it's only our consciousness or perhaps
that of the cat
which we can find as fundamentally
different here
maybe like descartes we need to hold
that there's matter and there's mind and
the two are completely different but
they interact if this were true it would
allow us to make sense of one of the
most troubling aspects of quantum theory
but what sense do we then make of a
non-material consciousness and how does
it cause the collapse of the wave
function
it may answer one question but it raises
several others
interestingly quantum theory has been
used in the opposite direction as well
that is in support of materialism
to give us a proposed material theory of
consciousness
sir roger penrose the british
mathematician and theoretical physicist
has argued that it's quantum effects
that give rise to the sense we have of
free will
dualism
that there's more to reality than just
matter and energy has to solve the
problem of interaction how do these two
different sorts of things work with each
other if they're completely different
materialism has no such problem because
there's only one kind of thing
but it has its own challenge free will
if the universe is just matter and
energy and these behave according to
well-behaved mathematically expressed
laws of nature
then we are just automata we have no
ability to do other than we do we do not
make choices we have no ethical
responsibility we don't live the lives
we think we live
there are two possible approaches for
materialists to take
first
they could try to save some sense of
non-determinism and human action based
on the laws of nature they can try to
argue that the universe is a
well-behaved place but that doesn't mean
that human actions are a deterministic
product of history and environment
the second approach is to give in on the
question of free will to accept that
human actions are not the result of
conscious deliberation
but to explain why they seem so much
like they are
they have to explain away our sense of
free will now
penrose
takes the former line
he starts with the simple proposition
that our actions are controlled by the
brain which is made up of cells called
neurons
all human actions even the simplest
movement require an incredibly intricate
choreography of neuronal activity
neurons throughout the brain form
intricate networks
neurons work together by the release of
chemicals called neurotransmitters that
allow for the flow of electrical charge
between them
when one neuron releases a particular
chemical into the gap between the cells
it will either facilitate or stop an
exchange of electrical signals
and it's the propagation of these
electrical signals through the brain
that result in the bodily movement now
one part of the neuron that aids in the
delivery of neurotransmitters are what
we call microtubules
these are small thin tubes of a protein
called tubulin
their shape
being long tubes and their presence in
all neurons has led penrose to consider
that they may be more than just pipes
it may be that the structure of the
inside of the microtubules is such that
it creates within the cell and then
between cells an entangled quantum
system
being inside of a tube this structure
may be sufficiently isolated from the
effects of the environment outside the
body on the brain to remain at least for
a while in a superposed state this
superposed state eventually is acted
upon by the chemical environment of the
brain causing the superposed state to
collapse and the firing of a particular
constellation of neurons
because this process involves a
necessarily quantum level process there
will be in this fully material system an
element which is necessarily
non-computable
in other words the brain is nothing but
a physical system working according to
physical laws but because the structure
of the brain is so fine there may be a
quantum level effect that makes our
actions not determinable we're governed
by the laws of physics completely but
that does not mean that our actions or
our intentions are uniquely determined
by the environment and the absolute laws
of the universe
further
since the quantum states of these
microtubules are coherent that is
entwined into a single system
it means that this sort of quantum
consciousness involves the structure of
the entire brain
the way we would expect it to so
free will
does not look like what we think it
looks it's not that we have a rational
agency that has no dependence on the
physical universe but
we're not robots acting at the whim of
absolute physical rules either
there's a controversy over this theory
and whether findings in neuroanatomy are
supporting or undermining the theory
however the idea that quantum effects
might be responsible for introducing
indeterministic elements into the
functioning of a material brain are one
significant approach to trying to
maintain the reductivist claim that what
physics says there is
is all there is
but
one can hold that they're only material
elements to reality and also hold that
the mind is not completely describable
by the laws of physics
recall that reductionism buys into two
different presuppositions first that
everything in reality is made up of
atoms energy and the stuff of physics
and second that the laws of physics are
all that's needed to explain the
behavior of these physical systems some
thinkers accept the first but deny the
second that is they hold that the
ultimate constituents of the world are
only things in the vocabulary of
particle physicists
but
that when you put them together in
intricate ways something new emerges
from the structure
and that it's greater than the sum of
its parts in such a fashion that physics
is insufficient to account for it
mind consciousness and life are emergent
properties that is they involve nothing
more than bits of physics but become
more than that when put together
properly
this view was championed in the first
half of the 20th century by the austrian
sociologist economist and philosopher
otto noira noirat was quite the
character a huge hulking man with
flaming red hair he had a loud voice a
booming laugh and a presence that
announced him in any room he entered
instead of a signature he signed his
letters with a cartoon elephant usually
holding a flower in the trunk
noirat was not only a powerful figure in
early 20th century social science but a
deep thinker about the place and power
of science
he believed that science education was
essential to social advancement and good
governance but worried that the language
of science mathematics would be
difficult for those who had to work and
couldn't receive higher education
he thought that science could be
communicated to the masses but it would
require a new way of expressing
mathematical relationships
a new language which was visually
evocative instead of using equations the
result was isotype a picture language
now we all encounter isotype symbols
every day
walk to a public restroom and figure out
which is the men's room and which is the
women's room by looking at the symbol
that was neurot go to an intersection
and know when to cross and when to wait
those are isotype symbols flashing at
the crosswalk
in theorizing about science
neurot disagreed with his fellow
thinkers in vienna who were arguing the
strict reductionist line he was a
sociologist and they were largely
physicists of course they thought they
held the key to all human knowledge but
physics he thought would never
completely account for complex social
interactions
not that it was irrelevant but that
there needed to be more at higher levels
scientific fields he thought were like
balloons placed next to each other
squeeze one and it expands pressing into
the ones next to them and reshaping them
causing them to push against those next
to them
physics and chemistry share a boundary
and it's a squishy one that's influenced
by pressures from both fields but while
one may help reshape the other they are
in the end separate balloons with their
own subject matters their own
vocabularies and methods to study
phenomena that happen at different
levels
chemical reactions are underneath
nothing but the interplay of atoms with
their various subatomic parts
but the complexity is in part due to the
chemical structures that require a
fundamentally chemical explanation with
chemical concepts and chemical methods
and so it is for biology psychology
sociology and
economics according to this view
the physicists may have given us all the
furniture of the universe but we can't
have a complete understanding of reality
if we don't pay close attention to how
the interior decorator functions
it's not just the pieces we need to
understand
but we'll redefine reality further if we
understand what emerges from those
pieces
and of all the aspects of the universe
that emerge perhaps none is more
intricate more fascinating and more
complicated
than life
[Music]
[Music]
you